عوده قويه لخالد يوسف في سر الباتع هو بين
دفعه لندن وكذبه ابريل ليلى عبد الله بطله
مرتين في رمضان والجمهور يتصيد ابرز اخطاء
دراما رمضان وقصه شيف جزائريه غامضه
تستضيف نجوم في الفضاء اهلا بكم
خالد يوسف مخرج سينمائي كبير غايب عن
الاخراج لسنوات وفي هذا الرمضان بسجل عوده
قويه للمشهد الفني ولكن من باب الدراما
ففي اول اعماله الدراميه بيقدم المخرج
خالد يوسف مسلسل سر الباتم اللي هو من
تاليفه اخراجه وقصه الراحل يوسف ادريس هذا
المسلسل الضخم انتاجيا واللي بيجمع اكثر
من 60 نجم ونجمه والاف الممثلين هو مستوحى
من قصه للاديب الكبير الراحل يوسف ادريس
وبدور احداثه في مرحله زمنيتين حول
السلطان حامد وهو بطل شعبي وقت الحمله
الفرنسيه بيتحول الاسطوره لها اضرحه
ومقامات في العديد من قرى مصر وفي بياع
مجوهرات بيلاقي نفسه بيحاول يكشف سر
السلطان واللي متابع المسلسل مثلنا اكيد
جالس متحمس علشان يعرف السر
لما الغزاه هجموا على مصر
قبلهم السلطان حامد وقال لهم
والله ما تدخلوا الا على جثتي
انا مش بدور على كنز انا بدور على حكايه
السلطان
مدى يا حبيبي السلطان
ملك يا حابب بلد احنا اتولدنا يا ابني
دايما المهام موجود في البلد الناس اللي
بيحفروا في المقام دول بيدوروا على ايه
الورقه دي شكلها من ايام الحمله الفرنسيه
العمل الضخم جدا انتاجيا مثل ما قلنا ومن
الاعمال اللي حاصدها النسب مشاهده عاليه
وعليها تعليقات وكلام كثير
ومعنا من القاهره المخرج الكبير خالد يوسف
اهلا فيك معنا خالد كل عام وانت بالف خير
كل سنه وانتم طيبين
وبارك لك على العوده الكبيره صراحه هو
صادم انك انت هذا اول مسلسل لك
صادم ليه
في الموضوع لانه كلنا متعودين انه عندك
تاريخ طويل وكذا وكذا وكذا يعني الواحد
لما بيرجع بطالع بيقول اه هو ما عمل ولا
مسلسل قبل كده
انا ما عملتش بس انا قدمت المسلسل ده قدمت
اكني بعمل فيلم سينما ما عملتش على ناس
التلفزيونيه اللي متعودين عليها يعني ايش
اللي غيرت فيه يعني
لا ما تغيرش حاجه انا بقول لك انا عملت
المسلسل اكني بعمل فيلم سينما
بنفس التكنيك بنفس
الاتقان بتاع
اللي بحتاجه عشان اعمل شوت سينما هو نفس
الوقت اللي خدته في صنع كل شط في هذا
المسلسل ما اعتبرتوش مسلسل
اعتبرته فيلم سينمائي طويل هو
في كتير على السوشيال ميديا بياخدوا لقطات
من المسلسل وبيحطوا فيها وبيشرحوا فيها
انه اخراجيا انت كيف عامل الموضوع بالفعل
كانه فيلم يعني بس ايش اللي لفتك تحديدا
في هذه الروايه وحسسك انه لا مسلسل مو
فيلم
يعني اما قريت الروايه زمان يعني انا
مشتري الروايه دي عشان اعملها من سنه 2009
يعني حلم قديم ليا من الافلام او من
الاعمال اللي انا كان نفسي اعملها من زمان
كان لان الروايه يعني بديعه
يوسف ادريس كاتب فيها فكره تقعدي تتعمقي
فيها تلاقي فيها
تطلعي منها 100 فكره او 100 خط درامي يعني
فلقيتها لقيتها كبيره تحتمل انها تبقى 30
حلقه من غير ما نعمل لمط ولا تطويل انت
عارفه احيانا الدرامز التلفزيونيه بتبقى
فيها فن مط وتطويل اللحظه لكن
انا عامل فن تكثيف في اللحظه زي ما بعمل
في السينما بالظبط
والدراما اكبر من النهضه يعني ممكن تتعمل
في 60 حلقه 30 حلقه هم يعني ومكسب جدا
الخطوط الدراميه يعني صحيح ايوه هو في
كثير خط الدراميه في القصه الان بعد ما
عملت هذه التجربه هل ممكن نقول انه
حتكررها هل حنرجع نشوف خالد يوسف خلاص
مثلا نجم النجوم رمضان دائما
العمليه مرهقه جدا جدا لانه انت بتعملي زي
ما قلت لك لما
لما نويت اعمل العمل عملته على النسق
سينمائي وعملته اكني بعمل فيلم فارهقني
جدا لان
حلقه يعني بتتكلمي في 16 ساعه ونص 16 ساعه
ونص دول يعملوا لي خمس افلام
يعني اعمل خمس افلام احسن يعني طيب فخلص
يعني نقدر نقول هذه التجربه حتكون الوحيده
اليتيمه يعني
تقريبا انا مش ناوي اعمل ضربه تلفزيونيه
ثاني يعني انا عملت ده اطلاله مني على في
البيوت كاريير تاني خالص غير السينما
وتمت اسهامي في الدراما التليفزيونيه لما
تتعمل من وجهه نظري تتعمل ازاي فعملتها
كمان طرقتوها ولسه بقيه الاحداث يعني او
بقيه الحلقات وكده اكتفيت يعني انا كده
مبسوط وصلت اللي عندك حاسس انه
يمكن واحده من الاشياء اللي بيتكلموا عنها
الناس او بيتكلم عنها حتى المسلسل الحديث
عن الهويه
المصريه الحديثه عن انه العلاقه بين مثلا
المسلم والقبطي وحتى الهويه المصريه من
منظور الفرنسيين او المستشرق وهو مثلا
بيكتب عن مصر والهويه المصريه والشخصيه
المصريه وما الى ذلك ليش حسيت انك مهم انك
تقدم شيء يحط الهويه المصريه في نقاط او
يوضحها
اولا هي الروايه قايمه على ده يعني
قائمه على فكره ان ليه الاستعمار الفرنسي
هو الاستعمار الوحيد اللي قاعد في مصر
ثلاث سنين فقط
لكل الاستعمار احنا عندنا 7000 سنه عمر
تاريخ مصر يعني
الاستعمار اولا استعمرنا تقريبا معظم
فترات حياتنا يعني 7000 سنه تقريبا احنا
مستعمرين يعني فترات طويله جدا ما فيش قوه
عظمى الا ما جات احتلتنا يعني وكانوا
بيقعدوا كتير قوي يعني اما تيجي تفكري من
اول الهكسوس اللي قعدوا 108 سنه مرورا بقى
بالبطالمه بالعثمانيين بالمماليك كل ده
مئات السنين قعدوا الفرنساويين قعدوا فقط
ثلاث سنين وهنا السؤال ليه دول بالذات
سنين فقط لان دول اقتربوا بالهويه الوطنيه
اقتربوا من محاوله تغيير ملامح الشخصيه
المصريه كل الاستعمار اللي جاء كان مستبد
كان فاشي كان ناهب لصلوات البلد كان كل
الاوصاف اللي ممكن تقوليها في الاستعمار
موجوده لكن ما حدش اقترب من ثقافه
المصريين ولا من محاوله تغيير ملامحهم ولا
محاوله تغيير عاداتهم ولا محاوله اضافه
منظومه قيم مختلفه مغيره المجتمع المصري
غير الفرنساويين عشان كده رفزوا سريعا جدا
المصريين هنا بيحصل بقى قرون الاستشعار
بتطلع
بتتحفز
وعملوا حتى بالعقل الجمعي مش ضروري يكونوا
واعيين ومحللين الكلام اللي انا بقوله ده
بس بالله وعي بتاعهم بيستنفروا فورا لما
حد بيقترب من هويتهم او ملامح شخصيتهم او
طريقه حياتهم او ثقافتهم بشكلها
فهنا الفكره اللي احنا بنقدمها في الروايه
في المسلسل ده انه
المصريين حاسين تجاه الهويه الوطنيه
بتاعتهم واتجاه ملامحهم
وده هيبقى له يعني كلام معاصر يعني انا
ليه جايب معاصر وليه جايب تاريخي لان احنا
عندنا تجربه اخرى في العصر الحديث اللي هي
الاحتلال الاخواني المصري لم يستمر اكثر
من سنه هو الاخر لانه برضو اقترب من
الهويه الوطنيه واقترب من محاوله تحت
تغيير ملامح الشخصيه المصريه برضو
المصريين استنفروا
وطردوه في سنه
فالمقاربه ما بين الاحتلالين دول هي اللي
استوقفتني وعشان كده انا عملت العصرين
يعني الروايه بتاعت يوسف ابليس ما فيهاش
عصرين فيها عصر واحد
فانا بشوف انه اولا التاكيد على الهويه
الوطنيه والتاكيد على فكره الانتماء
للدوله الوطنيه المصريه الجامعه يعني دي
مساله شديده الاهميه في كل زمان ومكان
يعني مش بس في لحظات التحدي ولا في فقط
ولكن ده مفروض طول الوقت ناكد عليه يعني
خالد يعني انه في بعض المشاهد اللي دار
فيها هذا الموضوع او تم ذكر هذا الموضوع
انه كان في مباشره او اسلوب مباشر او انت
متعمد هذا الشيء يمكن ما ادري يعني مثلا
لما تم الحديث عن مثلا انه القبطي والمسلم
والتاكيد انه نحن اخوان وانت معايا وانا
معاك والكلام هذا كله كان واضحه الرساله
مباشره
ممكن تعتبريها مباشره بس هي كانت مهمه
للفرشه الاساسيه عشان هتيجي ضمن الاحداث
اللي جايه وضمن كل التطور الدرامي اللي
جاي الحاجات دي في الاحداث من غير ما
نتكلم عنها فكان يمكن هي الفرشه ديت
الاساسيه خاصه انه كان مطروح السؤال انه
هل نحارب
الفرنسيين عشان هم احتلال كافر
احتلال يعني بنعتبره كافر ويبقى ويبقى
اكثر ضررا من احتلال المماليك ولا لا
هنا كان مهم ان احنا نوصل انه ما تفرقش
احتلال شكله ايه
والناس اللي بتخلط ما بين
ما بين
المسيحي الفرنسي مثلا والمسيح المصري لا
المسيح المصري هو المسلم المصري يعني دي
برضه قضيه اشكاليه موجوده على الارض طول
عمرها بالتاكيد عليها يعني فكره ان في حد
يقول لك ان المسلم الاندونيسي اقرب لي
مثلا من المسيح المصري انا ضد الكلام ده
انا المصري هو المصري ايا كان ديانته
اكيد عليها كان بعتقد ان مهم وجبت احتياط
الدرامي اللي هم كانوا بيتناقشوا في نروح
نحارب الفرنساويين ولا لا يعني
لازم نحاربهم بس خليني كمان خالد يمكن
عشان انقلك لنقطه الثانيه صار جدل على
موضوع الموسيقى صاروا بيقولوا انه خالد
يوسف بيستعمل مقطوعات موسيقيه سبق
واستعملها في افلامه لاي درجه هذا الكلام
صحيح
كلام صحيح جدا بس يعني الناس دي بتنسى بس
انا عملت فيلم اسمه حين ميسر تمام هذا
الفيلم ما استخدمت ما عملتلوش مزيكا ما
عملتلوش ما جبتش موسيقارى عشان يالف له
مزيكا انا خدت مزيكا افلامي السابقه كان
فيلم خدت مزيكه فيلم العاصفه
للاستاذ كمال الطويل
وخدت مزيكا ياسر عبد الرحمن في خيانه
مشروعه وعملت بيهم مزيكا فيلم حين ميزره
بالكامل بالكامل وكتبت على موسيقى كمان
الطويل وكان توفى حتى وخدت طبعا الاذن من
من ولاده يعني ان انا استخدم المزيكا
واستخدمتها هي ومزيكا ياسر عبد الرحمن انا
رايي انه
المشكله المزيكا وجدان اي عمل فني بالنسبه
لشغلنا يعني فانا لما بحط تما موسيقيه
وبتعلق بها وما بعرفش اشوف المشهد من
غيرها ما بقدرش اشيلها يعني ساعات بحط
مزيكا جيد عقبال ما نعمل المزيكا وبعدين
بعد ما اجي احط المزيكا اللي اتعملت مخصوص
ما احسش المشهد زي ما كنت حاسه لما كنت
حاطط المزيكا الجيد فبقول لا خلاص هسيب هي
مزيكه قفلاني وانا مستاذن اصحابها فايه
المشكله مش فاهم انت ليه في النهايه تقول
والله المزيكا مش معبره لك والله تقول
والله انا ما عجبتنيش خالص ما عجبنيش
المشهد حقك المطلق وانا حقي المطلق ان انا
استخدم المزيكا اللي انا عايزها يعني ما
تقوليش انت هتستخدمش ايه يعني انت كمشاهد
وناقض من حقك تقول ان المزيكا غير معبره
غير محيه لم تضيف بعدا يعني كل ده من حقك
لكن مش من حقك تقول لي استخدم دي ولا ما
تستخدمهاش طيب اسمح لي يعني خالد خليني بس
كمان اخذ بعض التعليقات الناس واسالك عنها
يعني احنا رغم كل الحفاوه طبعا والاشادات
اللي صايره حوالين المسلسل حابه انه نكسب
انك معانا علشان نستعرض معاك كم تعليق من
التعليقات الناس اللي من ايام تم تداول
صور مثلا مشاهد من مسلسل سمعها البعض
اخطاء تاريخيه بعضهم سموها اخطاء اخراجيه
يعني فمثلا ظهور احد الممثلين بحذاء رياضي
لاحدى الماركات العالميه اللي ما كانت
موجوده في هذاك الوقت في كمان سوره الفنان
ايمن اللي بيقوم بشخصيه نابليون وانه طويل
القامه ونابليون عرف عنه قصر القان ما غير
الصور اللي تداولت عن لبس وملامح الجنود
الفرنسيين
خليني يعني ابتدي معك بهذه النقاط يعني
اللي الناس تتحدثوا عنها مثلا مشهد حاجات
كتير منها الحاجات اللي حضرتك قلتيها
وغيرها وانا هرد لك عليها يعني
اللي بيتكلموا على
معلش قولي لي التلات نقاط مثلا قصه الحذاء
قصه الحذاء انا عندي الف كومبارس
تمام او الفين كومبارس في اليوم الكنترول
عليه يعني فكره ان انا وبحرك المجاميع دي
في معركه
الشركه عليهم من المساعدين برده يعني ما
هو ما كانش 100%
فحصل لما حصلت هذه الغلطه انا اكتشفتها في
التصوير مش في مش بعد ما اتعرض
وعملت اخر شيلت الولد الكومبارس اللي كان
لابس ده وجبنا ولد ثاني كان لابس الجزمه
التاريخيه هو ثاني كسر ان هو يلبس الجزمه
يعني
وقعدت الشوط وحطيت الشورت الحقيقي وحصل
غلطه في تركيب المسلسل انه حط الشرطه ده
بدل ده تايم كود غلط محطوط واول ما اتعرض
المسلسل فورا في اول بعد اول عرض شفت
البتاع قلت لهم يا جماعه الشوط اتحط غلط
بدلت وخلاص يعني يعني خطا وسهل صحيح بعتذر
عنه لكن ما هواش بقى هو ده انا
جايب ضارب بعرض الحائط وبلبس الناس كوتشي
وماركه يعني مش معقوله يعني لازم كل هذا
الجهد وعامل كل هذه الملابس التاريخيه
المنضبطه وحركه المجاميع دي كلها والاف
المجاميع وهاجي على حذاء لواحد من
الكومبارسات وهعمل فيه يعني كمان علقوا
على الملابس قالوا انه بعض الملابس وانه
تاريخيا وما تاريخيا والاشياء هذه
والاشكال الاشكال اشكال الجنود
يعني اللي اتكلموا على الملابس
القطن القطن المصري القطن المصري ما كانش
موجود ده محمد علي اللي جابه من الهند دي
بقى فزلكه من طراز رفيع يعني لان القطن
المصري
اللي جابه محمد علي من الهند اللي هو
القطن طويل التيل لكن القطن المصري موجود
من 7000 سنه والملابس القطنيه موجوده ثم
بقى افترضي ان ما عندناش قطن مصري انا
عايز اعرف مين بقى الجميل العظيم اللي قدر
بقى يخش جوه الشاشه ويمسك القماش كده
ويقول لا والله ده مش كتان ده قطن ده ازاي
يعني يعني
فكره ان انت تلبسي اعداد المجاميع دي كلها
ملابس
بتزعجك لما انت عامل عمل بهذه الضخامه
ويجي احد يعلق
نيش خالص ده بتعمل
واهتمام وده ساعدني وما فيش عندي مشكله
خالص بس يعني
في محاولات
اما تيجي بقى تتكلمي على نابليون يعني
برده يعني
الناس اللي بتتكلم كده يعني ما تعرفش يعني
ايه فن اصلا يعني لما جاء يوسف شاهين عمل
فيلم عمل فيلم ناصر صلاح الدين الناصر
صلاح الدين ده كان وصفه تاريخيا عريض
المنكبين طويل ما اعرفش ايه الى اخر
الكلام ده اوكي احمد مظهر ده طوله 165 سم
يعني حضرتك اطول منه
هو الحقيقه يعني يا خالد لو انت عرفت طول
الحقيقي ما كنت هتقول الجمله هذه لانه
احمد مظهر اطول مني بكثير الحقيقه يعني
الله يرحمه
احمد مظهر كان قصير جدا كان 165 سم 168 سم
يوسف شاهين جابه وفي دور ناصر صلاح الدين
محدش قال له ما اعرفش ايه الرؤيه بتاعه
المخرج في اختيار الدور يعني لو انا بقدم
نابليون انا عايز اقدم نابليون عظيم مثلا
غير لما اكون عايز اقدمه ومستبد غير لما
اكون عايز كل واحد انا عايز اقدم جمال عبد
الناصر ان هو اعظم شخصيه تاريخيه
فبجيب الكاستنج اللي يحقق اللي اللي
يكسبني جوله في في الرؤيه بتاعتي لو عايز
اقول استبداد
فبرضو الكاستنج تلعب على موضوع الشكل
ما بجسدش انا شخص يعني لما عملوا نيكسون
لما عملوا نيكسون جابوا جاك نيكلسون
ما عملوش حتى تاتش مكياج
دول كانوا بهايم دول يعني
ما قالوش علاقه خالص واخده بال حضرتك
وجابوك وعملوا زي ما هو لان القضيه مش
قضيه تطابق الشكل القضيه قضيه رؤيه المخرج
في الشخصيه نفسها
فمش قضيه ان انا بتجيب واحد اهو ده كان
واحد معاصر بقى ميكسون كان معاصر نيكسون
معاصر وعايش مش بقى واحد من التاريخ هو يا
دوبك مرسومه له صوره انت انت وراك صوره
صاحيه خالد
هو الوحيد
الصوره الوحيده اللي وراك
لا ورايا جيفارا ورايا عبد المنعم رياض
وقدامي جمال عبد الناصر وقدام يوسف شاهين
اهو اوريكي
يوسف شاهين وده بن ناصر وده عبد المنعم
طيب يلا حبينا نطمن على الغرفه والصور
طب بقول لك يعني في محاوله للفزلكه
والدعاء واللي يقول لك مثلا ما كانش في
عجله تجرها احصنه في هذا العصر يعني جبت
منين هذا المصدر العجيب يعني اذا كان
المصريين يعرفوا العجله الحربيه من ايام
احمس منك من كام الف سنه يعني اللي يعرفوا
حضارتهم العجله الحربيه اللي بيجرها حصان
هيقعدوا الاف السنين مش هيتفتك ذهنهم ان
هم يعملوا عجله بيجرها حصان للحياه العامه
يعني ففي محاوله للتصيد طول الوقت ومحاوله
لانه حد يبدو ان هو عالم ببواطن الامور
اللي يقول لك القطن المصري ما اعرفش ايه
واللي يقول لك العجله ما كانتش موجوده
واللي يقولك لانك انت خالد يوسف ولا تصيد
عام
هو التصيد بالعموم من السوشيال ميديا
عامله هذا
بشكل عام لكن انا انا انا شخص مثير للجدل
طول الوقت وفي ناس طول الوقت يعني يعني
اعتقد المسلسل ده لو عليه اسم اخر غيري
يمكن ده كله ما كانش حصل وكانوا قال والله
ده فتح جديد في الدراما التليفزيونيه وانه
[ضحك]
على العموم يا خالد الناس بتتابعه وبتتفرج
والمسلسل عامل اصداء مره كبيره انا شاكره
جدا انك انت اعطيتنا اليوم من وقتك
وطبعا ساعه صدرك انك انت لتقبلك كل الاراء
والرد عليها
في الاراء ولا حتى في الفزلكه يعني ببقى
سعيد لها وانا في النهايه عامل عمل انا
سعيد به وفخور بيه وعملت ما املك يعني
والحمد لله الاخطاء صحيح والاصدقاء باينه
كبيره والاهتمام كبير فعلا
المسلسل ناجح وعلى نسبه مشاهده يعني
طب خلاص بقى اللي عايز بقى يقول شويه
حاجات كده في النص ويعمل بوست حلو ويتشير
ماشي مفيش مشكله
اوكي نشكرك على وجودك معانا كان معنا من
القاهره المخرج الكبير خالد يوسف شكرا لك
يا خالد
[موسيقى]
النجمه الليله عبد الله بالطل على الجمهور
في الموسم الرمضاني هذا ببطوله عملين
الاول دفعه لندن اللي بتكون فيه بشخصيه
مضاوي طالبه بالسنه الثالثه من كليه الطب
ابوها من اغنى اغنياء الكويت وماجر
الطالبات غرف معاها في شقتها وبتكون
مداومه من البنات اللي ما يميزوا بين
الخير والشر والاستغلال والطيبه
الجدل في هذا الموسم وكنا تكلمنا عنه امس
حتى من ناحيه بعض العراقيين اللي اعتبروه
مسيء ومهين لهم لانه احدى البنات عراقيه
بتعمل خادمه وبتتهم بالسرقه هذا بالاضافه
الى كلمه معينه قالتها كمان احدى البزلات
في مشهد معين وعملت جدل واعتبروها الناس
غير لائقه وكانت ليله طلعت وردت على الجدل
حول الكلمه وقالت انه ردات الفعل كانت
نفاق مبالغ فيه وانه الكلمه ما فيها شيء
وعادي جدا وبالنسبه للجدل الاخر ما تكلمت
ليلى وقالت انه كل شيء في وقته حلو اما
العمل الثاني اللي بتقوم فيه بطولته
والمسلسل الكويتي كذبت ابريل اللي بيتكلم
عن اسره تاجر معروف على مستوى المجتمع
بيقوم بدوره الفنان الكبير جاسم النبهان
وبتكون زوجته الفنانه الكبيره زهره عرفات
وبيعيشوا في الظاهر حياه مثاليه ولكن بعد
وفاته بتكتشف تفاصيل صادمه
الافكار والاوهام اللي ببالك المريضه هذه
يشيليها اول شي يسووها راح اخذها حبيبتك
واستغلها هلقط ام هالقطه
رحمتك بيبي اللي انت ما تشهد الا باسمها
نفس اللعبه بس علشان تحرق قلبي انا البنيه
اللي هديتها
الفنانه ليلى عبد الله اهلا فيك معانا يا
ليلى وكل عام وانت بالف خير يا رب يا اهلا
يا اهلا ساره الجميله شلونك شو اخبارك يا
حبيبتي عيدي موضوع الجميله مره ثانيه
بالله
بقول لك عيدي لي موضوع الجميله علشان
الزملاء اللي بيشككوا فيها
مزهزه
تمام
ليلى خلينا نبتدي نتكلم عن بطولاتك هذه
السنه طبعا انت ما شاء الله كل سنه بتعملي
ادوار والكلام ده كله وصلك يعني كم سنه عم
تعملي ادوار جدليه وماخذه وعامله الجو
السنه برضه دفعت لندن جدلي جدا كيف صرتي
من اعضاء الدفعه
اولا طبعا يعني انا الحمد لله سعيده يعني
بالنجاحات هذه اللي قاعد تصير وسعيده
وفخوره طبعا بكل طاقم العمل وكل زملائي
اهنيكم وان شاء الله بعد في الايام
القادمه راح تشوفون حلقات
يعني مهمه وجدليه اكثر وفيها رساله وفيها
فن وفيها جماليات كثيره كيف صرت اعضاء
الدفعه والله السنه اللي طافت احنا صار
لنا طبعا ثمانيه اشهر قاعدين نشتغل على
المسلسل كلمتني الاستاذه هبه مشاري حماده
وقالت لي انا شايفتك في دور مضاوي واجري
المسلسل قولي لي يعني اذا حبيتي وبس وصارت
واشتغلنا والحمد لله طلعت لمن قراتي الورق
ليلى حسيتي انه حيعمل ضجه اكيد توقعتي
صراحه شوفي انا ما ما اتنبا للمستقبل يعني
وانا اقرا يعني الاعمال لان اكون
بحاله فنيه وايد شديده يعني اكون مندمجه
مع الادوار والشخصيات والشخوص وطبعا كنت
غرقانه في زمن الثمانينات وكان عاجبني
الكلام
والشخصيات كلها كلها حبيتها وتخلت قلبي
طبعا انت لما تقرين من واحد ل 30 متواصل
في اربعه ايام كانك تقري في روايه
دائما يعني لمن ادخل اي عمل اتنبا ليا يا
رب وادعي النجاح هذا اهم شيء عندي
الجدل ويصير ولا بتسوي ضجه بصوره ما ادري
شلون يعني مو من
اهدافي بس لا اقول لك مو من الاشياء اللي
احطها في مخي انا اهم شيء عندي النجاح
يكون للعمل طيب هو العمل ناجح طبعا بس
عامل يعني بموازات النجاح هذا في جدل
موازي لهذا النجاح وبحجم هذا
النجاح لما نجي نتكلم عن مثلا
بعض الكلمات اللي قالوا الناس اعتبروها
مثلا خارجه وكذا انت حضرتك طلعتي ودافعتي
خليني بس يمكن اعرض لك كليب صغير من كلامك
اللي قلتيه بس
دائما احنا يعني مثلا احنا اغراضنا كاغراض
بنات ما يصير نقول حرام عيب كل شيء
بالخشوه كل شيء كذي يعني ما ينقال انا
اشوف ما ادري انا اشوفه مبالغه بالنفاق
صراحه يعني انا كل مره قاعد اشوف نفاق
زياده وزياده بطريقه خلاص اني تعبت منها
انا بالنسبه ليك يا ليلى انا قاعد ابرر حق
ولا احد انا بالنسبه ليك ليلى انا احس انه
انه اعيد مو تبرير حق ولا حد انا احس ان
الكلمه ما فيها شيء وبدي ودي اقول عن
القضيه الثانيه
لكن ان شاء الله كل شيء بوقتها حلو يعني
كل شيء يعني بسولف عنه بس كل شي بوقته حلو
وشكرا
طيب اول شيء خلينا نتكلم عن النقطه الاولى
ما تحسي انه من حق الناس انهم يتحسسوا من
بعض الكلمات اللي بيعتبروها حساسه خاصه
مثلا
لا
طبعا من حقهم يعني انا مو ضد ان احد يقول
رايه ولا ينتقد ولا حتى يطلع ويسب يعني
بالنهايه يعني هذا جمهور وكلامهم دائما
على عيني وعلى راسي ولا اخص بالكلام الاحد
انا دائما
اتكلم عن رايي الشخصي انا هذا رايي الشخصي
انا طبعا فيه يعني
بس انا بحتفظ فيه لكن انا اتكلم في نقطه
اني اشوفه هذا جزء من الواقع يعني هذا
كانت قاعده بنات وكنا قاعد نتكلم عن شيء
معين وان قالت الكلمه بغض النظر صح ولا
غلط لكن انا من باب انه هذا اول شيء واقع
بس قلتي منافقين
انا ما جمعت ساره ولا خاصيت ولا يعني حددت
يعني فئه معينه لكن انا في فئه معينه في
بالي تكلمت عنها ويمكن خلاني تعبير شويه
وانا اتكلم لكن كان كلامي كله
بصوره شلون اشرح لك اياها اكثر دفاعا عن
كل ما انا اشوفها واقعيه وان قالت بين
بنات
واحسها انه بالنسبه لي انا كليله انه يعني
ممكن تنقال في اطار معين درامي في سياق
يعني موضوع يخدم المشهد واشوف انه ما فيها
شيء لو انت قلتي كمان يمكن نكته في كثير
ناس بيتكلموا عنها الان بشكل عام يعني حول
العالم يعني انه قصه انه الاشياء اللي تخص
المراه يعني دائما فيه انه اوبس لنقولها
اوبس عيب نقولها اوبس لازم نخبيها
ايه ان الاشياء هذه انا شويه لانه يعني
خلينا نقول مع حقوق المراه يعني فاحس ان
شويه الموضوع اثارني اثارني من داخل انه
في اشياء ممكن تمر وفي اشياء ممكن ما تمر
لانه تخص المراه لكن اي هذا كان رايي انا
ودائما احس انا بالسناب شات يعني مكاني
الخاص بيني وبين متتابعين اللي يحملون نفس
مبادئ ونفس ارائي ونفس افكاري لو جيد انك
تطرحي وجهه نظر في وسط يعني كمان وجهات
النظر المتداوله يعني بنسبه معك وفي ناس
ضدك عادي
[موسيقى]
العجاله في الحكم على المسلسل
احنا تونا اليوم في سبعه رمضان يعني
الاحداث اللي جايه بالمسلسل راح تكشف
الكثير الكثير
من الاشياء اللي راح تنصدمون يعني انا
يعني اقول حق المشاهدين والمتابعين انه
راح يشوفون شيء جدا جميل راح يشوفون طبعا
ليله الاستاذه ليلى واحنا بنتكلم انا
معاها راحت رمت لي قنبله عن الاحداث جايه
قلت لها ليه يا ليلى انا بتابع المسلسل يا
ليلى ليه ليه ليه خربتيه الدنيا يعني وانا
طبعا يعني انا والله شوفي انا سعيده طبعا
بالمشاهد الذويق يعني وطبعا استانس لما
اشوف في حاله من من اثاره الجدل واثاره
الجدل يعني اثاره العقل
الحلو ان الناس لما تتناقش وتشوفوا بس
دائما يزعلني سرعه الحكم سرعه يمكن كمان
تحديدا خلينا نكون صريحين اكثر ليله بتحكي
على موضوع الكثير ناس اتهموكم في موضوع
الاساءه للمراه العراقيه
طبعا اكيد يعني الاشياء
يزعلني طبعا لان مثل ما قلت لك احنا
بالنهايه يعني فنانين نحمل رساله سلام
واحنا ناس جدا مسالمين وبترك انا بقيه
الابابه للاستاذه هبه مشاري حماده ايوه
جاوبت واتكلمت اكيد يعني راح يكون في
توضيح اكثر ومثل ما قلت لك انا اخاف اني
اتكلم واحرق الموضوع لا لا خلاص كفايه
الله يخليك الله يخليك ابغى اتابع المسلسل
خليني انقلك على كذبه ابريل مختلف تماما
دور كذبه ابريل
الحمد لله انا كنت خايفه من هالنقطه يعني
كنت دائما
مضاوي ورزان يكونون يعني مختلفين علشان
الناس انا يعني كنت ادري ان الناس راح
تحبها المسلسل وراح تحبها المسلسل فكنت
ابي ان الناس تشوف ان هذا غير وهذا غيره
الحمد لله يعني صابت
كذبه ابريل يعني كذا في دراما اللي هي
بتصير يعني مثلا ان العوائل والاشياء هذه
كله وفيها الموضوع قديش الرجال كذاب
واناني واشياء من هذا النوع بتشوفي بتتفقي
مع هذا الموضوع انه الرجال كثير كذاب
واناني
الرجال كثير كذاب واناني يعني طبعا
يعني بعد العالم ما يخلى يعني من
الانانيين وقلت لك هذه قصه موجوده يعني مو
الكاتب هم لمن قال لي اياها قال لي انه هو
استوحاها من المجتمع
مسلسل طبعا ساره مثل ما لاحظتي ان كل سنه
انا اطلع بعملين عمل جريء وعامل يعني
يناسب
على هذه السيره ايوه انا كنت بدي اسالك
يعني السنه الماضيه من شارع الهرم الى
يعني كسرتوا الدنيا ما تركت احد ما اتكلم
عن العمل وحتى انت وقتها كان عندك دور
وهاجموكي وقالوا انه لانك طلعتي على
الميزان وقالوا انك انت لابسه مع انه ما
كان باين الا رجولك من تحت يعني ما في شيء
صاير في هذا الهجوم على وقتها على هذا
العمل وعلى علاقتك مع زوجك في هذا العمل
وكذا ايش يعني ضايقك وقتها
شوفي وقتها كان ضايقني لان يعني انا كنت
ابي تكون المعركه معركه مرض مرض البوليميا
معركه انسانيه مو معركه جسد ولا معركه
يعني
ذكرى
مبتدله على قولتهم يعني انا انسانه جريئه
ولكن مو مبتذله وهناك فرق كبير بين الجدل
والابتدال دائما يصير في ايه يعني دايما
يصير في بين الاثنين لا واكيد انت في
المشهد يعني رجولك اللبانه الحقيقه يعني
هذا موضوع قديم وتعدينا وتخطينا منه وانا
دائما يعني مثل ما قلت لك اقدم عملين عمل
بالناس اللي تحب انه تشوف
يعني شلون اشرح لك
بليفل معين وعمل لي انا ليلى الفنانه اللي
يبي اوصل يكون لصيت بالعالميه فاللي حاب
يشوف هني اللي حاب يشوف هنيه ولكم حريه
الاختيار لا اكيد عامله عمليه فعلا
مختلفين والاثنين عاملين يعني صدى رائع
جدا ليلى انا دائما احب اتكلم معاكي
ودائما يعني سعيده بظهورك معنا شكرا لك
اليوم حبيبه قلبي وان شاء الله نرجع نشوفك
على دبي الحق نفطر ولا نتسحر سوا
تسلمي لي كانت معنا الفنانه ليلى عبد الله
شكرا لك يا ليلى شكرا يا حبيبتي شكرا
التصيد الاخطاء في دراما رمضان هو مسلسل
بحب ذاته ففي كل موسم درامي رمضاني
بيبداوا المشاهدين من اول يوم يطلعوا
اخطاء سواء اخراجيه او دراميه او في
التصوير او حتى اخطاء تاريخيه خلينا
نستعرض مع بعض اكثر الاخطاء اللي الناس
متداولتها من اول رمضان والبدايه من مسلسل
الزند ذئب العاصي اللي هو بطوله النجم تيم
حسن ومجموعه من النجوم الاخرين ومن اخراج
سامر البرقاوي الناس تداولت صوره لمشهد
بيظهر في اللوح طاقه شمسيه على سطح احد
المنازل مع انه احداث المسلسل بتدور في
نهايه القرن التاسع عشر في عهد الدوله
العثمانيه يعني اكيد ما كان في الواح طاقه
شمسيه وقتها اما المسلسل الثاني فهو مسلسل
ستهم من اخراج رؤوف عبد العزيز واللي
بتقوم ببطولته الفنانه روجينا واللي
تداولوا الناس صوره لها بتبين فيها
ابتسامه هوليود واللي هي اجراء تجميلي
معروف في الاسنان بيزبط الاسنان او بيزبط
شكلها والناس استغربت الموضوع كنروجينا
بتادي دور سيده فقيره في الصعيد ويعني مو
لايقه على هذا الدور وهذا التعليق تحديدا
ما جاء بس لانه شفنا كثير تعليقات على
اسنان فنانين وفنانات اعتبروا الناس انها
مو لايقه على الادوار اللي بيقدموها هذه
غير التعليقات الدائمه على الفيلر
والبوتوكس وغيرها
مسلسل سر الباتع اخراج خالد يوسف واللي
كان ضيفنا في اول الحلقه كان له نصيبه من
الاخطاء والانتقادات وتناولناها في بدايه
الحلقه ورد عليها المخرج تكلمنا عن لباس
الجنود الفرنسيين
وملامحهم وطول قامت الفنان اللي بيؤدي
شخصيه نابليون واللي معروف عنه انه قصر
القامه المخرج كريم الشناوي هو كمان لقت
لنفسه خطا في عنوان احدى حلقات مسلسل
الهرشه السابعه وتداركوا واعتذر عنه كمان
وهو خطا في كتابه عنوان الحلقه مثل ما
شايفين كيف مكتوبه كلمه استحمى وكان
المخرج مثل ما قلت تزارك الخطا واعتذر عنه
وقال انه تفسير ومو تبرير الخطا ومن اخطاء
المسلسلات المرصوده كمان خطا اتكلمنا عنه
في حلقه امس وهو من مسلسل رساله الامام
اللي بيروي حكايه اخر سنوات من حياه
الامام الشافعي فشفنا الشاعر سوري طلع
واتهم صناع المسلسل بسرقه ابيات شعر هو
كاتبها وتم نسبها للشافعي وذكرى في
المسلسل على لسانه على انها من تاليف
الامام هذا الخطا الكلام بالعاميه مع اكثر
من تعليق اخر كانوا صناع المسلسل حاولوا
يتعاملوا معاهم كلهم واضافوا تنويه في تتر
المسلسل انه هذا مو مسلسل تاريخي بل
معالجه دراميه لكن اليوم على فكره شفنا
تطورات في القصه فالشاعر صعد اكثر واعلى
المقادات صناع المسلسل وبدء اتخاذ
الاجراءات القانونيه ضدهم وعلى فكره
المراجع والمدقق اللغوي للعمل كان طلع في
بوست على فيسبوك وهو رئيس مركز اللغه
والثقافه العربيه في جامعه القاهره دكتور
احمد عمار قال في بوست على فيسبوك سماه عن
فضيحه الامام قال لو ثبت انه الابيات مو
للشافعي فهذا خطا لا يغتفر ولا يمكن
الدفاع عنه باي شكل من الاشكال وقال انه
ما كانت شغلته المراجعه التاريخيه وهو بس
كان بيدقق لغه وقال انه مو شغله المدقق
اللغوي البحث في مرجع النص لكن في هذه
الحاله كان عليه الانتباه الى الكسر
العروضي في الشطر الاول ويبحث عن اصل
البيتين لكن لم ينتبه لهذا مع انشغاله
بضبط النص واعتذر عن هذا الخطا الكبير مثل
ما سماه رغم انه مو المسؤول عنه على الاقل
ام وليد سيده جزائريه اسمها مو غريب على
الجزائريين ولكن شكلها مجهول وغامض
بالنسبه للكل بما فيهم متابعيها يعني ما
هي فزوره فام وليد هي صاحبه قناه او صاحبه
قناه ام وليد على يوتيوب ومتخصصه بالطبخ
وبتعرف عن نفسها انها قناه خاصه بالطبخ
السهل بمقادير مضبوطه خاصه لكل مبتدئه
ولكل امراه وعلى القناه في 11 مليون و700
الف مشترك واكثر من مليارين ونصف مشاهده
هدول كلهم جمعتهم ام وليد عشان يتابعوا
فيديوهاتها للطبخ اللي ما بتبان هي فيها
وما بيسمعوا الناس الا صوتها وبيشوفوا
الوصفات
السلام عليكم اليوم مع وصفات ام وليد هذه
الوصفه اللي خفيفه شوفوا مقادير قليله
حضرت بهم زوج وخبيزات بهذه الطريقه نكوره
غير شويه شويه لانه كيما ذكرتها شويه بارد
بهذه الطريقه اذا ها هو الباذنجان بعد ما
حمرته في الفوق
ام وليد تفاجات الناس هذا الموسم الرمضاني
بدخول مجال الاعلام وطلت على البرنامج في
برنامج طبخ سمته الفضاء ام وليد على قناه
سميره تي في لكن برضو من غير ما تكشف وشها
ام وليد كانت رمضان الماضي شاركت في فقره
طبخ على نفس القناه والسنه صارت مقدمه
البرنامج وفي بتستضيف فيه فنانين ومشاهير
على متن مركبه فضائيه وبيحضروا او بيحضروا
خلال الحلقه وصفات متعدده ام وليد ثابته
على موقفها وما ظهرت ابدا وبتدير الحلقه
وهي جالسه في غرفه ثانيه وعبر الكاميرات
ومكبرات الصوت وحتى فريق القناه ما يعرف
شكلها لانها بتسجل الحلقات بنفسها وحقيقه
البرنامج لا قصدي احسان منقطع النظير على
المنصات وكثير من الناس اشهدوا بام وليد
اللي قدرت تحقق شهره كبيره من غير ما تظهر
للعالم
ومشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انعود
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه الخميس
الونيس اجمل ايام الاسبوع في امان الله
[موسيقى]